rêve des fonctionnaires ce jeudi dans
les yvelines dans l'éducation nationale
au total seulement 18 % du personnel
était en grève
ils réclament une hausse de leurs
salaires et protestent contre la
suppression de postes
c'est la première grève menée par la cgt
fsu solidaires depuis le début du
quinquennat de françois hollande c'est
la première c'est une façon de prendre
date sur la défense des services publics
qui ont été très malmené ces dix
dernières années et qui en dehors de
l'éducation continue à l'être dans le
projet de budget la grève est peu suivie
dans l'agglomération la plus grande
mobilisation se situe à trappes
au total sept écoles ont fermé quatre
maternelles et trois primaires à voisins
le bretonneux seule l'école de la
pépinière n'a pas ouvert ses portes ce
matin
dans les autres communes les
établissements étaient ouverts mais
certains services ne sont pas assurés à
la verrière il n'y a pas de garderie de
restauration ni d'animation dans les
écoles du bois de l'étang et du parc
élémentaire le service minimum est en
revanche mise en place à montigny le
bretonneux quart 25% d'enseignants sont
grévistes
les fonctionnaires étaient 5,2 millions
à être appelé à la grève ce jeudi à
travers 120 points de rassemblement